you're running a great company and now
you're having your livelihood destroyed
because I can't get somebody to answer
the phone at the d-o-t in that one
department that that's not acceptable
in 1993 a Chinese immigrant named Pei
Lin Liang was working as a delivery van
driver for a noodle factory in New York
City when he had an idea to run a local
van service for garment workers between
Chinatown in Brooklyn and Chinatown in
Manhattan I discover I have a lot of the
business so I feel like a SAP company
phone wok trust but yes four years later
Liang extended his service all the way
to Boston to Chinatown business exploded
the work offer the mouth so Liang
purchased a handful of full-size motor
coaches and Fung Wah became the very
first Chinatown bus company picking up
and dropping off passengers right off
the street curb other Chinese immigrants
imitated Liang older bus companies like
Peter Pan and Greyhound which were
losing their customers to the Chinatown
operators launched their own imitation
curbside bus companies
thanks to pay Lin Liang curbside busing
is now the fastest growing mode of
intercity travel in the United States
a year and a half ago Fung Wah was
forced to stop operating its buses by
the federal Department of Transportation
and today the company is on the verge of
ruin liang who once sat on top of a mini
busing empire has taken out a second
mortgage on his home and now spends his
days teaching music lessons to help pay
his bills he's consumed by one goal
depressed Eliza's Drew Carey is in New
York city-based attorney who represents
many bus operators who are in the exact
same predicament what happened was
because of concerns and maybe legitimate
concerns about first of all the increase
in bus traffic in this country which
actually is laudable because buses are
so safe so much safer than passenger
cars but because the bus industry was
growing by leaps and bounds and so then
you were seeing more accidents and
hearing about them in the media so that
there was an increase in oversight of
these bus companies Carey doesn't object
to safety enforcement but to the way
it's been carried out after the federal
Department of Transportation forces her
clients to stop running their buses the
agency keeps them in an open-ended
holding pattern as it deliberate over
their fate the problem is once you get
in trouble with them they don't have
time frames people can't keep operating
without any profit for endless endless
months without any reprieve the closing
of Fung Wah was a complete miscarriage
of justice in the first place as reason
reported last year the government
botched its safety inspection and Fung
wahs buses were perfectly safe to
operate when the Department of
Transportation forced them off the road
last year but an even greater injustice
is what's happened in the year and a
half since after Fung Wah was closed
Liang threw himself into saving his
company over the next few months he
spent about four hundred thousand
dollars overhauling his fleet retraining
his drivers hiring a full-time safety
manager and paying a consultant to make
sure that all his internal paperwork
complied with federal regulations Liang
showed the agency all of his new
initiatives and the Department of
Transportation upgraded Fung Wah from an
unsatisfactory to a conditional safety
rating at that point
I've been off the road for about five
months so these are big changes and
you've shown those changes to the
department transportation and now you're
good to go or so you thought
Liang had one more thing left to do to
get his operating authority back fill
out an application and mailed to the
Department of Transportation in
Washington so that the agency's staff
could decide whether they were confident
that he would abide by the rules in the
future he sent in that form on July 31st
2013 and then you wait and there is
nothing in the statutes the federal regs
there's nothing that says how long
they're going to take lawyer drew Carey
has several clients who've waited longer
than six months for the Department of
Transportation to consider their
applications I call Council and I get
someone who knows nothing about my case
my particular clients case other than -
I sounded like we were on the phone that
she was maybe looking them up and and
then she was able after many minutes of
talking to her to say that we were
number six and I said what does number
six mean and she said I can just only
tell you that you are number six and I
said well where did I used to be she
couldn't tell me that and I said and how
long does one through five take couldn't
tell me that like all bus operators
waiting to hear from the Department of
Transportation Liang had to keep paying
rent on his office's interest on his
loans the insurance on his buses the
salaries of his core staff and his
lawyers fees total how much of he spent
in the year and asked
three meth renu-it three newing time
periods are what are what give you
fairness in law you're having your
livelihood destroyed because I can't get
somebody to answer the phone at the
d-o-t in that one department that that's
not acceptable
six months after submitting his
application and nearly eleven months
after he was shut down
Liang finally got a response from the
Department of Transportation his
application to start operating again was
denied but the agency didn't give any
explanation as to why all of the new
safety measures put in place by Fung Wah
weren't sufficient so Liang's attorney
filed an appeal another six months
passed last week the Department of
Transportation finally responded a full
year and a half after Fung Wah was
forced off the road the agency is now
asking the company to submit more
written evidence that is equipped to
operate a safe bus service in response
to our inquiries a spokesperson for the
Department of Transportation defended
the pace of its safety reviews stating
we have a responsibility to ensure that
bus companies are fully willing and
capable of abiding by federal safety
standards before allowing them to resume
operations
ever put the opposite of fun upset and
something some welfare is the anger
there oh now what happened that the
crocin the company is a good company
what happened
I believe Anwar will be absolutely be
back in business if mr. Liang has the
financial wherewithal to hold on that's
the question do I believe the agency
will eventually approve them I do
because you know why it's the fair thing
it's the right thing to do
they've done everything that they were
asked to do and more